Dyson products have always been the  result of rigorous design research and  innovation every one of our product  launches begins with a marriage of form  and function and the trend continues  with the new dicey boldly the fastest  most hygienic way to achieve total  scraping join us every second after 9.2  5 gallons of HEPA filtered air is forced  to 0.8 millimeter wide apertures  creating 420 mind that our sheet saveher  that swaddle your parents in just 12  seconds or six seconds purple also  included for your nether region a  patented telescoping a tape drive the  dyson ball blade because every package  should be handled with care  trust me they work they really do work  you